this was a lot of fun to do an interview
with brett sir dallas who's written a
wonderful new book called golf's holy
war a little bit provocative but the
battle for the soul of a game
in an age of science so that appealed to
me for sure
i took away a few really interesting uh
thoughts
after doing the interview which uh came
a little bit surprising to me and i
think
i think you'll really appreciate them it
was really interesting to hear
brett's take on tiger woods i hadn't
planned to talk much about tiger
woods but as you'll hear tiger actually
has a huge influence
not only on the way that brett and
others uh visualize their golf game and
try to work to improve but also on the
meta process of learning how to learn
to be a good student and scholar of
anything and i think
that applies equally well to physics as
we discussed as to golf
i also found it interesting to know
notice how golfers are now using
principles from physics
and physiology to improve their game to
get some say an
unfair edge and i think again that goes
above
just the mere subject of golf itself
into meta concepts of learning and and
how
to really become an expert by putting
together
stacking together different skills from
science to
physical fitness etc and i think those
can be applied in almost any endeavor
so that was quite lovely and also
obviously the comparisons to moneyball
which i felt are not incredibly accurate
that have been made including on the
cover of the book by some of the
blurbers as we say
but i found brett to be incredibly
interesting
scholar very curious and very humble
and i'm proud to uh to have had him on
the podcast so i hope you enjoy it
please subscribe leave a rating and a
review it really helps me out
we're doing quite well in the ratings
and but we can always do better
with your review rating etc so keep
uh tuning in stay creative stay
imaginative
uh and i hope you enjoy this episode
with brett cergalis on
golf's holy war
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
so it's a pleasure for me to welcome to
my
uh podcast today the author of a science
book
we normally have a predominance of
scientists but not always but this is a
new science book
and it's a book uh especially physics
and it has on the cover uh a very
interesting
you know giant nucleon uh called the
golf
the golf on or in my case the bozo on uh
and that's brett cergalis am i
pronouncing your name right brett bretz
or gallus
you are ryan you nailed it i've heard a
lot worse believe me
sarah jealous and yeah i worked on that
for about three weeks
it wasn't as hard as i interviewed a man
by the name of patrick that david who's
uh
who's uh originally from iran and i
learned how to say
my name is brian keating the host of the
into the impossible podcast welcome on
the podcast to
to mr bet david and uh he just said
thanks it's nice to be here i'm like
that took me oh it was in farsi by the
way
and i was like that took me like three
years to memorize and that's all i get
as a thank you he's like oh i thought
you were persian
um anyway one thing i wasn't uh when i
started reading your book
was a golfer but since uh a variety of
different compounding forces that i want
to get into
i've become a golfer and i really i
didn't think i would appreciate the book
as much as i did
because i wasn't interested in golf you
know when i picked it up i think it came
out in may right or
in the spring and it looked interesting
and it has a very provocative title
which i want to get into right away but
uh but you know wasn't super into golf
and then this summer thanks to kovid
i got really into golf and played my
first 18 holes of golf
um over the span of three days that's
how long it took me to finish 18 holes
uh but uh i really was magnified my
admiration and my pleasure uh because of
your books i want to thank you very much
for writing golf holy war or
the battle for the soul of a game in the
age of science
and that portrays science in a very uh
you know kind of
questionable light so i want to i want
to first ask you i always judge books by
their covers i don't care i judge books
by their covers by their pictures
uh by the titles and their subtitles how
did you come up with the title cover
and subtitle of your wonderful new book
well uh
the title just came to me one day when i
was thinking about it really
um you know the subject as i explained
kind of in the prologue it was a uh it
was a it was a long time ago and it was
something that
kind of hit me quickly was that wow
there's this conflict and as a writer
you
this is what you look for right you look
for conflicts um that are interesting
and both sides are
have some validity to them um and the
title just kind of game
just came to me at some point i don't
know how or why
um but it did and the subtitle has has
gone through a couple different
iterations
um finding out that the uh the
editor of simon schuster doesn't like
gerunds
in his subtitles wasn't was a new one so
i had to go back to
my uh you know freshman english class in
high school and remember what a gerund
was
so my last name my last name is jared
right yes it is
yeah you're right that explains why i
didn't get a book deal from them
uh and the cover was actually um
a lot of them i had a great editor this
guy uh joffee ferrari adler
who you know they have a whole marketing
department
um and he was like you know what do you
think
what are your i what are you envisioning
and i envisioned
something a lot starker and serious
and i think that was their first idea
was pretty much that
and i thought it was a little cartoony
um but
you know after a while like i didn't
have any better ideas they they had a
hundred more
uh ideas and that one was still the best
one and i said
you know i don't know what i'm doing so
i don't want terms of covers
so if you guys think this is good and
you know what's funny is
is you're not the first one to mention
it how it pops too and i finally
for the first time last week i went into
a bookstore it was the first time i've
been in a bookstore
since the book came out and there it was
sitting there face out which is
what you want in a bookstore and the
cover really popped so
i'm happy it didn't turn out the way i
thought in my head and i'm happy
they have pros doing that kind of thing
yeah there's only one downside it
doesn't show up well against my green
screen
in the background because that's that's
part of the they've done psychological
studies that green really pops out
because it's almost unnatural
yeah really get drawn to it i want to
ask about the writing process that you
employed i mean as a first-time author
uh but i mean a first-time book author
but a long time writer
new york post and other outlets which i
want to get into
what was that switch like going from a
you know kind of daily grind or so to
speak
uh quite frequent uh deadline writing to
writing a book that had
i mean as far as i can tell no deadline
no news hook
uh other than you know the summer
season's nice to have books about golf
out i imagine but what was the
difference in writing you know kind of
when you're on deadline
versus your off deadline what's your
kind of routine and how did it differ in
writing this wonderful book
it was really it was really different
and i had to i had to detach
myself i had to do them at separate
times where i found out that i was very
productive early in the mornings um
so i'd wake up early you know 5 30 6
o'clock and i would work on this because
i'm
it was my mind was quieter it was you
weren't overwhelmed with
even if you were even if you looked at
the internet even if i looked something
up
on the internet there was no i wasn't
getting emails i wasn't getting
you know uh notifications on twitter and
whatever else like that's
there just wasn't anything going on so
that was when i was most productive
uh working on the book because then once
i got into deadline
writing and regular writing then it
becomes like a you're turning it around
you're doing it fast you need to
you need to be quick uh and you need to
get to the point
um and there is an art
in that um that a lot of people are have
you know forever have been way better
than me
uh at bringing out that artful side of
of that kind of writing
um but it's different so i i you know i
kind of tried to detach the two and
and working at the paper i mean we have
there's three major daily deadlines
right so and if i'm covering a game um
then it's like as the game's going on at
night there's different deadlines it
becomes
it becomes chaotic right until
until you're done and it's not it's one
in the morning and then you hope you
didn't make a mistake
right and so uh working on the book was
i signed the
um i signed the deal with simon schuster
in 2012
and it came out in may of 2020.
so there was a couple full drafts
um you know where i got told hey good
cool you did it now redo it um
and the book is infinitely better
because of such good guidance from
people that have done that before so
the process was way different um but you
know there are some things that carry
over i think one of
you have to be concise as a writer you
have to get to the point
and you have to shy away from purple
prose and overstating things
and um yeah i think that that translates
and
the one thing i will say about the
timeliness of the book was i had a lot
of
oh crap moments because science is
constantly changing as you know as well
as anybody right
so the science of golf is changing too
so i was as things were happening it was
oh no i don't know about that
like oh no and then i'd have to go look
it up be like okay either
something has to change in what i did or
i have to learn about this and write
about it so
there was a lot of that over seven years
of writing it
um but uh i what i tried to do is make
it you know
as timeless as possible at the very
least this will be
a what is modern there is a snapshot of
a period of time
rather than hey look at what's breaking
right now it's no here's a snapshot of
what i
found to be a super interesting moment
in the history of the game
uh and maybe you can look back on it in
30 40 50 years and
and see a description and a proper
description of how
you got to how the game got to where it
is yeah and it did evolve
uh so much even over that relatively
brief in the
span of things i mean you talk about it
being the oldest if not you know one of
the oldest about the oldest games in the
world that's still
more or less played as it was back
originally in scotland
um and uh around the world it's it's
changed but
a lot of the change has accelerated
exponentially and i've had peter
diamandis on my show and he talks about
the exponential
growth of technology and its impact to
better society is a techno-optimist
and i came away from this book um first
of all you know i really appreciated the
appendix full of all the equations from
general relativity and string theory
membrane theory that was
very impressive for a for a sports
writer at the post
i commend you on no they stephen hawking
said once that you know every equation
cuts your readership in half
so so luckily your readership will
remain undiluted
i found it very interesting though that
there's only one i listened to the book
on audiobook i loved listening to it i
felt like
as carl sagan would say you were inside
my head relating ideas
uh you know from from one brain to
another brain it was a wonderful
read book by the reader i forget his
name but uh but it was quite well done
but there's only one picture in the
physical book and i won't spoil it
for people who i want people to buy the
book i never asked the authors to
disclose the entire thesis of the book
the takeaways of the book you know
i want people to buy the book in every
form possible but there's only one
picture in the book and i wanted to just
comment on that and
before we leave the topic of books and
writing the writing process of books in
general
and that book that picture is of your
library so why that picture why was that
the only picture you decided to include
well in terms of when i started thinking
about a bibliography
it's impossible because everything i've
ever read about the game is essentially
in the bibliography so it would be
every issue of golf digest and golf
world and
um but i did buy an excessive amount of
books uh for doing it as my wife will
testify
um and so i thought it would be really
cool to have the bibliography and so
it's a select i wanted it to say select
bibliography
and be just a picture of the bookshelf
because the book this bookshelf behind
me
that's just golf books right um
and there's more there believe me
there's more books hanging around
uh i have i have a growing uh science
physics
part of the uh of the library as well in
which you are included
i'm looking i'm looking for it i don't
see it in the book it's uh
you're not engulfed your book is right
there actually
right under mine sitting horizontally oh
yeah i see
it there and i think stefan alexander's
books up there
there it is and that's uh adam becker's
book what is real
and then brian green catalog is around
somewhere and
i think uh sir roger penrose is over
there as well
um
um so uh yeah i wanted that's what i
wanted
by the bibliography to be it was just
that picture and the editor was like hey
that's a really good idea but you know
there actually needs to be a
bibliography as well so
yeah that's the one picture where it you
know the idea is that
there is such an extensive
literature of the game that's arguably
the best literature in sports
um you know george clinton's favorite
line that the uh the smaller the ball
the better the writing
um so you know there's some of the
some of the best writers who dabbled in
sports have written about golf so i
i think it's important to be well read
to write something about the game to be
able to
know the different perspectives so that
was just a snapshot of
kind of some of the reporting and some
of the
uh you know research that that went into
the whole thing
yeah we have an analogous thing the
smaller the particle the better the
writing
so i want to turn to the book itself um
you know the book has it
has this kind of contrasting dualistic
nature in that it's a
it's a book about uh it's a book about
science and the impact of technology and
science
but it's also a book about for lack of a
better word spirituality and soul
and which did you come away feeling more
you know plays a bigger role as a sort
of like a character device or perhaps a
plot device rather
you know the science side of it or the
soul side i would say they kind of share
you know equal amounts of ink uh so to
speak so which
did you come away from your research and
uh and your explorations and interviews
etc
uh feeling is more at the heart of the
game
uh the the soulful side spiritual side
the mystical side of golf
or the scientific calculated and not
saying cold in a negative word but the
analytical side of golf
i i think there's a balance i think
every great player
every great coach has had a balance
between the two
where there is a there is an
understanding of
mechanics right so there's an
understanding of the physical
science that goes into it but you it
can't just be that
there's more there's more to executing
athletically
than just understanding the physical
science of things so that is where
the kind of spiritual soulful side of it
is too because
it takes it takes a lot especially when
you're trying to play
under pressure um you can't just
tell your body to execute and this you
know this goes into neuroscience
and psychology and all of this stuff how
do you
how do you execute physically um so you
need to have
some understanding of your mechanics
right but
there's more to it there's there are
questions um
that aren't easily answered uh that go
into being able to do that um so the way
i approached it
was as objectively as possible
where i said i i'm a reporter right and
i find
uh there to be validity in both sides of
this argument
so i want to i want to give
i don't know it's pretty close to equal
space probably it's somewhere it's
somewhere near it where it's
if you want to if you lean one way or
the other you can see the
the possible uh goodness in the other
side
um and maybe you agree with one more
than the other i think we all do
and i think that's just a uh i think
that's just a point of
of all of our brain makeup it's just how
you are as a person how do you learn
um and that's a lot of part of the book
is is learning how to learn and
when you understand your own self you
understand which way you lean
a little bit more and you understand why
and it's not to say one is better than
the other
it's just a matter of who you are as a
person
uh and how you how you go about learning
um in any in any aspect whether it be in
the classroom or
on the driving range so it's those two
those two sides of it um i know where i
lean
but i don't think that was i tried not
to make that part of it this isn't
i'm i wasn't trying i was doing my best
to not make it an
argument here's a thesis here's my
argument and and
i'm going to convince you so a lot of
the feedback i've gotten is from people
on either side going
man there's way too much science in
there or going there's way too much of
that
hippie-dippy bs in there you know it's
one or the other because that's just the
way people are
uh and and that's kind of what i wanted
i wanted it to be
accessible to both sides of the argument
and both sides hopefully learning
something about the other side
and yet i came away uh with the
inescapable
comparison to michael lewis's money ball
and i think a lot of people have noted
that
and that's high praise for your writing
and for the subject matter at hand
of course in moneyball i think it's hard
to argue that
uh there's also there's there are also
in uh baseball there's two sides
two you know there's a soul of the game
and then there's the metrics and so
forth brought to the game
but i think it's hard to argue that
things like you know the shift and you
know different pitching
you know configurations and and all the
technology
that that's employed in baseball not
just analyze
outcomes but to pre-game each player and
like i said the shift
i don't think that that's benefited
baseball i i don't think it would say
you could benefit the soul of the game
of baseball by having the shift it may
make it more efficient
it may make teams better have better
chances to win
uh but in golf do you find that same
kind of asymmetry exists
where you know the science can can be
good
uh for improving individual scores but
does it really detract from the soul of
the game
in the same way that sabermetrics or
whatever did in many people's opinion
mine included
detract from the soul of baseball so all
right so there's a slight distinction
between moneyball analytics
and analytics and golfs because there's
two sides there's the analytics
of your golf swing so a lot of what i
talked about was the science the
teachers are using
to help players get better
right give them be better more efficient
golfers but the analytics that is
analogous to moneyball and baseball
is the analytics of shot link and how
pga tour players are playing the game
and on the golf course so i don't know
how much you watched the the us open
this week but bryson d chambeau is a big
story
guy he gained 40 pounds he hits in a
million miles
and that's because he found a a
loophole not a i don't know how much a
loophole but he
he found in inequity in the stats of the
pga tour where
if you drive it that far you are going
to have a
great chance to win no matter how else
you do everything else so then that's
just a reflection
of the golf courses that they're playing
and how they're set up
so that is where that is
closer to moneyball where he found
he found an inequity right and he said
okay well you can't
you really maybe you can compete and be
a short hitter on the pga tour now
but you will not be a great player
unless you
every week week in and week out unless
you hit it a million miles
so unless they totally change the way
they're setting up golf courses
that is what he found so that is that is
similar to the shift
or finding a player or understanding the
importance of on base percentage
or something like that uh which is a lot
of money ball
but the other side the other side of the
analytics would be analyzing the data
you get
from ball flight monitors and
force placed in 3d motion analysis and
stuff like that
which is at the forefront of the game so
being able to
understand that is is is a little bit
different because now
goth is such a i find it to be one of
the most interesting games because it's
so internal
so you don't there isn't a team you
can't kind of just
follow you know if you're a running back
you
you have a play and you and you execute
the play and your training is getting as
good as
as in good shape and as good as you can
but you're still executing what somebody
tells you in golf
when somebody tells you to do something
in your swing you can't just
change it like your brain and your body
just don't it just doesn't work like
that
and so it's all about where you are
internally so
uh so that side of analyzing the data
and
understanding spin and and everything
all of the million things that can go
into it is a different type of analysis
and that
and that is where coaches are now too
where they are pretty much
disseminating data and information and
then they have to understand
what to give the student because every
student's a little bit different
so there are some
a coach would be remiss if they didn't
understand
the data and if they didn't use the
science at their fingertips but they
would be just as
negligent as if they gave all of it to
their student to every single student
because not everyone learns the same way
and i know for me personally i wouldn't
want to hear all that stuff it would
confuse me i don't like looking at
myself on video
you know and but there are some people
that every they want to look every
second
um so how you analyze it
it changes from you know are you
competing on the pga tour
there's that's the kind of analytics
that there is
at that level and then there's analyzing
the data
to help you whether you're a pga tour
player or you know just started the game
two months ago
there's understanding that as well and
how that affects the
the soul of the game um
to me it it can like where baseball has
gotten a little less interesting i think
the pga tour has gotten a little less
interesting too
and personally when amateurs play the
game you kind of have to understand what
draws you to it
what do you enjoy do you enjoy hitting
balls on the range
and getting a little bit better and
seeing better numbers on a on a ball
flight monitor or do you like the
sunshine do you like walking do you like
talking to people do you like
having fun and getting better and
hitting better shots but in the context
of enjoying what the game has to offer
so
there's soul means something different i
think for everybody
and it's just a matter of how you kind
of interpret it
yeah i think that's uh that's that's a
really good summary of kind of what i
took away from the book which is that
you know you might not be able to make
use of a you know a
pitching analytics amazon web statistics
for
baseball but you won't have
an ability to really oh the launch angle
was 109.3 degree okay
good for you but but you know to the
weekend golfer
uh that's not like uh there is much more
potential for improvement as you point
out
i think i also want to ask about you
know the impact of physics literally
pun intended uh with bryson specifically
i was reading over the weekend that he
uses all the same length
clubs which is 37.5 inch length and i
want to ask you about that
is that you know kind of another form of
metric or
scientific analysis that he's employing
to to do that or is it just for
convenience or for muscle memory
no he so he uses uh all of his irons are
the same link so like his driver is a
little bit longer
um he he originally employed
so i get into this book in my book i get
into this book about called the golfing
machine
which uh has it's pretty much a
huge malleable equation where you can
create your own
swing and you can you can become a
golfing machine
so he had one of these setups where it
was okay
you hear here's how your wrists are set
here as you swing on one plane you do
this
and he found it easier to execute
through the bag if they were all the
same length
so um when they started selling those
commercially i thought it was a really
bad idea
and they still sell them and i don't
mean to uh poo poo
any uh manufacturer but it's a really
bad idea
for for amateur golf like you you really
should not
go to a and buy a store and just buy
those off the rack like you will
struggle
the long irons will be way too hard i
mean the short irons will be way too
hard to hit
you're not going to swing it like that
anyway um with the proliferation of
of club fitting custom club fitting
anyway
it's it doesn't make any sense but
that's what he thought he thought it was
easier to execute the way he swung
with with those clubs so he already said
like next week he's going to start
experimenting with an even longer driver
to hit it even farther
so um you know he's he is what he is and
he's i think he's really interesting
and he's and he's good for the game
because maybe people that are
inclined to think like that are are
going to be drawn to him and
are going to want to watch him yeah well
it's certainly inescapable that there
are certain physical advantages and you
point out
uh the physical but also the mental side
but i
i found it also like a stealth
psychology book and how these people
kind of get along
with their teachers and the mentor you
know uh
men mentos i don't know mentee protege
protege mentee uh relationship and how
you know that range from disparate
forces going back to hogan to to tiger
woods
to you know modern golfers uh as you're
talking about
i wonder you know if you if you look at
that and you have
really some wonderful statements about
teaching
and that's obviously a big important
topic to me as a professor
and as a parent i think there are
different uh rules in there but
you talk about and you said something
very interesting in the book you make a
distinction between teaching
versus fixing and you say the clear cut
really
distinction there is the role that
curiosity
plays and i wonder if you could uh
expand upon that this is you know the
podcast for the arthur c clarke center
for human imagination
we think about curiosity a lot how does
curiosity play a role
in the differing teaching methods that
you describe in the book
yeah you know as i as i got later i
realized that
a big part of this well all right so
i'll give the anecdote of
um there's this great teacher out here
on long island actually his name is mike
hebron
and there's a whole chapter about him
and so he was he was national teacher of
the year
in 1991 and he was very technical and he
used the golfing machine as kind of his
uh his template and then eventually he
started getting
students that came and some were getting
better and some weren't and the ones
that weren't getting better he
made him very frustrated he didn't
understand why i think every teacher
golf pro professor i'm sure it's
it's very similar in where you don't
understand why some students are getting
it
some aren't and so he realized that he
didn't understand anything about
learning and how people learn so when so
he started
taking class he took classes at harvard
and mit and
ucla and he learned about how the brain
works
and what they've started to understand
is that
you learn a lot better through failure
and experience than you do through
explicit
information that you learn better
implicitly than you do explicitly
so the way he started teaching was a
is in almost this abstract kind of way
where if you want to be a better
chipper he now kind of has you throwing
tennis balls tethered to a uh
you know a lanyard so that you learn
rhythm and
and and that's it and so his thing was
you kind of know what to do and when you
watch little kids
taking golf lessons specifically you see
them learning
just a lot easier than adults because
they're just playing
and so you play to learn so to me that
that was the most
interesting thing is that and and and
when you go and you go if you
do these case studies of how people end
up how great athletes happen right how
people on the pga tour or in the
olympics
it's odds are they they came from an
eclectic background
and and this idea of being super
specific is now
it's science is bearing out that it's
not it's not good
it's harder to become an elite athlete
with
by just playing baseball your entire
life or just playing golf
uh it's better to play different sports
because then you learn how to
you learn how to be more athletic right
you learn you learn balance and hand eye
better than you learn how to do some
specific motion over and over again so
then you can adjust on the fly and you
understand
you know you understand really you
intrinsically understand the physics of
it a little bit better without actually
understanding
physics um so to me that's
that's the best part and of this whole
process is that you end up getting to
this point where it's okay here's all
this data and here's all this science
and the best thing to do to get better
is to play
just go and play and experiment and
everybody hits shots differently you
know and look at where the ball goes and
react to where the balls go and try to
hit it
in you know where you want and the more
you do that
with yourself with some kind of minimal
teaching you don't need to be over
taught it's more just being pushed in
the right direction and
show that your curiosity will result in
in getting better if if you're willing
to keep playing
um and i think that's such a healthy
lesson
for the way that we like our whole
society has become so
litigious and over taught and and
specific and it's better if you just go
out and play because that is actually
how your brain works
you know that is how you get better that
is how you get smarter
aren't the books that stuck with you the
most brian the ones that you picked up
on your own
not that a teacher gave you yeah so
maybe
maybe a teacher knows you and says you
know what you're going to really like
this and then that sends you down a path
and that's what happened to me i'd
assume that happened to most people you
know
and uh so that's kind of the thing and
if it's in golf specifically it's
well go and play and enjoy it and don't
start
don't start hating it it happens to a
lot of kids who are who are young that
want to
play in college and go so forth and
where they start hating it and they get
burnt out
because it's just too much and i'm sure
that i'm sure that happens in
academia constantly too yeah now it
happens extremely frequently and
you know the takeaway i get from from
that you know section of the book
is that one and and i believe this
applies directly into teaching physics
or teaching
painting or whatever and it's that the
first and most important lesson
is to you know kind of coach somebody to
be coachable because if somebody's
coachable
and they start young uh there's almost
no limit to what they can do i mean
we're all born with the same
you know talent so to speak to to
acquire things that we're curious about
and that role of curiosity really does
separate the
really high flyers the successful people
in any endeavor
and i think you know i look at something
like tiger or you look at someone in
baseball
you know who studies the game who really
focuses in on the game
uh loves the history loves the classics
same in chess and any kind of uh
you know skill game or or strategic game
as golf is certainly
uh founded upon uh but i think what's so
appealing to me about
about the book and about the sport in
general is that it has these many
dimensions and so it's
it's kind of like as deep as you want to
go if you want to go
you know really sparse you can go back
to the old country right in scotland you
describe
how sparse and spartan the the original
you know highlands courses were and
people still love it i mean they pay
thousands of dollars to go and play
today
or you can go to torrey pines where it's
pictured in uh and behind me in my
screen which is only a couple miles away
from campus
and from ucsd which is one of the many
reasons i like to try to recruit
students to come here if they're
interested in golf
and i actually was at the 2008 us open
that tiger woods won but i left before
he won because i i left on the sunday so
he went into a monday playoff i i think
if i recall correctly and i i was like
leaving on sunday and i was like ah we
get out of the parking lot before it
gets too crowded it's like i heard this
eruption when he sank some what
you could tell better than me some very
long putt yeah
and uh and you know and much to my
chagrin i should have stayed and watched
it because i was a classic for all time
how much of a role does tiger continue
to play in golf
um obviously his career is punctuated i
want to talk about the more
tawdry aspects of it i think i leave
that to your colleagues on page six
over there my favorite section besides
your writing uh but
um but you know his his sort you know
subsequent comebacks and
and declines etc how big an effect is is
the tiger effect still to this day
it's huge it's huge to me tiger is
is the modern golfer uh he took the game
from this from where it was as a kind of
a
nichey pastime uh you know you go from
you go from bobby jones into hogan into
nicholas
and it's still kind of it grew and
arnold palmer had a big part of it
growing in the masters
but you know it was always kind of a
country club
type thing right and there was a very
small group of people that were super
interested in it and that was it
and then tiger took it from that era to
this one right where
everything he did mattered so and
when he got into science in this and all
of the science that was coming through
that's when everybody else got into it
and you you look at the
at the young guys that are on the tour
now and and they openly admit it i mean
bryson openly admitted after he won the
u.s open that
they are all inspired by tiger and
they're inspired to get in better shape
become better athletes
tiger you know took golf and dragged it
into
the modern era and so what i think
in my book where it's this conflict
between science and art
he has balanced that as well as anybody
so i get asked the question a lot too
you know do you think he would be
better do you think his career would
have been better if he didn't get so
bogged down in technicality and teaching
and the answer is no it couldn't have
been anything but what it is
because that is who tiger is that is who
he was in that moment he he was
infinitely curious about what was out
there
and that was part of what made him great
so that is why he went from
you know from teacher to teacher and
method to method because he kept needing
to get better and he kept needing to
learn and learn and learn that was just
the way he was so
if that if he that would that's like
saying if he wasn't tiger woods would he
have the same record it's like
that's just who he is and that's that's
where he went so i
and i still think i still think he is
that guy and i
i he i hope he will be i hope he doesn't
kind of
fade away and he's going to stop playing
at some point he's going to stop being
less
of a force in the game but you know
where does it leave
the game now it's that i mean we can
talk about that for hours and
and where the state of the pga tour is
and uh
and where it might go from here without
him um because it's a really interesting
question but he
he did he did kind of modernize the game
and he's still
you know there's only a couple guys on
in golf that move the needle and he's
still number one by
leaps and bounds yeah and he's so
influential culturally
outside of golf obviously with the
impact of race and
and being uh you know multi-ethnic
multi-racial
uh such an interesting person and uh so
it was so obviously accomplished and
uh you know it's hard to find people
that are role models despite having
fallen from grace and of course you know
there's no such thing as a as i always
point out you know when someone's
trying to date or whatever i say there's
no such thing as a perfect man
you know my wife got the last one but
the but the point i think
about tiger is that he you know if you
if you look at him
and how much of a scholar he was i mean
he's probably got a bookshelf that will
make your put your bookshelf to shame
uh because he is such a student of it
and naturally i think it's unavoidable
reading
this book you know a question that
you've probably been asked a million
times but i'd like to be on the record
you know uh on the into the impossible
podcast which is you know how good do
you think someone like
ben hogan or ben crenshaw or
arnold palmer would have been with the
technology tdi
you know these club analytics the um
the the the technology that really
started to come about in the early 2000s
intimately connected with like military
technology which you point out so
interesting
uh but uh but with the technology that
we have available today how good were
these golfers of your
well how good would they have been i
think it's impo it's impossible
to speculate because it was it was just
different you know it's just different
um because would ben hogan's swing look
the same if he was using the technology
that they have now
no and then how if his swing wasn't the
same would he be as good
right so it's it's it's almost
impossible i mean bobby
jones was using hickory shafted clubs
and was
and was playing with with gutter perches
that were
pulled out of trees right like rubber
that was pulled out of trees so
it's impossible it's impossible to know
just as it's impossible to
go and reverse and say how good would
bryson be if he was playing against
bobby jones in
in the 20s you know you have no just no
idea you can't
it's it's impossible it's impossible to
speculate
it's like saying you know how how good
would how good would uh
a modern scientist be back if they were
dealing with einstein before
relativity or something right or
einstein with a super computer right
that's that's what i was thinking about
right
right exactly well exactly how good
would einstein be with a super computer
you have no idea because he didn't even
know what a computer was
right so you have you have no idea how
uh
how these errors compare when they're so
different
um it's i mean it's it's it's fun to
argue
who was better in their time in their
moment
um you know was was
bobby jones better in his moment than
tiger was in his
um or was nicholas better i mean
nicholas career was so long
uh and constantly successful that
to me he's the best player of all time
but is tiger the most talented is tiger
you know i mean
things things are so are so different
and they're it's fun bar room talk
but i think it's impossible to to put
them together and say you know how good
would uh this person have been in a
different era because it's just
the games are just just so different
it's funny that you mentioned that
because i think it's natural to
speculate
not only bar room wise but also because
the game itself is so historic
that you look back on you know the sport
that's you know
basically unaltered in a certain sense
you know you're chasing around this
little ball in a beautiful setting in
nature and it's really something you
can't do indoors in a
you know in an enclosed stadium uh and
uh and it does lend itself to
technological improvements i think and
and i think the the impact of technology
on the average person you know i once
heard it said nobody looks at
michael jordan you know taking off from
the free-throw line on a dunk and says
i'm going to do that this saturday at my
you know my pickup game but everybody
looks at you know tiger woods you know
hitting a three foot you know from the
upper right on a par three it's
i could probably do that you know um but
in reality i think there's the
technology not only in swing dynamics
etc
but also in the club technology in the
course design
and there's a lot of interesting
developments i
quite frankly as i said i was never
interested in golf my
uh you know brother to his chagrin would
always try to get me interested
and it wasn't really until i had kids
and now i've got an old enough uh
son and and uh you know my kid can take
me out and he can
you know do almost as well as me and i
think that's kind of the great equalizer
it's
it's it's sort of a chance to spend
uninterrupted time usually in a pretty
nice setting
but i wonder you know if it's not out of
reach for many people and what the
impact of that is going to be and what
the pga
thinks about that so i wonder what's
sort of the future of kind of especially
with covet etc
uh what's the impact likely to be of the
cost of golf and maintenance et cetera
and technology
for for getting youth more interested in
the game
yeah you know that's it's a really it's
a really complex and interesting
question um i think one of the one of
the most attractive
things about the game is is how
when you go to a great old golf course
you are you are walking in this
footsteps of people behind you and
you're walking in the footsteps of
history so you go to torrey pines and
i'm sure how many people hit that same
putt that tiger made on the 72nd hall
you know and everybody wants to do that
and in no other
in no other sport you know can you go to
lambeau field and
let's say play a game maybe but you're
not playing
in front of the people you're not doing
it's not the same thing and like
no you can't right maybe they'll let you
in the doors but you're not going to
play a football game
there anyway but you can go to saint
andrews in scotland
where they've played the game for a
millennium
and walk in this in the in the same
footsteps of old tom morris and
and you know and jack nicklaus and bobby
jones and tom and tiger woods
and you can you can hit the same shots
it's like
interacting with this piece of art that
other
places won't let you you know you're not
it'd be like you know having an art
class in the sistine chapel or something
it's like
which is not even close to being the
same thing because you're
you're interacting with something so
special
and then you get a you get a feel for
for what those people went through
because you're looking at the same green
you're looking at the same tee shot
and you're hitting it you're having to
do it for yourself you get it's it's an
interactive
experience um and that is what to me
that's one of the biggest things that
draws me
to the game and one of the biggest
problems
that the tour the pga tour and or the
governing let's just say the governing
bodies of the game faces because
these great golf courses are slowly
getting obsolete with
the way technology has gotten so it's a
problem
that the game really the the biggest the
three biggest reasons the game
is shrinking um is it's too hard
it's too expensive and it takes too long
and that all to me all three of them
come back to the golf course
because the god if you know there was
this trend in
architecture um through post-world war
ii boom where everyone wanted a
championship
golf course and this happened again in
tiger boom where they wanted the harder
the better
right and that means longer it means
uh which is more irrigation right more
water
it's more land so now it costs more and
because it's harder it's going to take
you longer
so it's more difficult to get people
into the game
on golf courses like that where to me
the best golf courses being built
the best golf courses ever built are
challenging the scratch player
and equally as fun for the guy who's
trying to break 100
because and they're the hardest ones to
design
because it takes so much thought going
into them and you have but you have to
be able that's the way you're bringing
people in
um you know it has to be there has to be
more
fun alternatives to it and they have to
be drawn by the top it's always from the
top down so the pga tour has become this
this kind of diluted product uh where
you know four weeks a year matter the
majors matter
you know uh once the ryder cup once
every two years matters but even that is
not there's not
really a lot of golf it's more the
height that is that has surrounded it
and the other years are are just not and
the other tournaments are just not
super interesting i mean i i probably
like golf as much as anybody on the
planet
and a lot of the other tournaments i
don't watch intently because
i don't really care who wins because
they're not that interesting and what's
going to make them interesting is
is is better golf courses and better
marketing for the players
and and having that come down to
the people who are playing and so the if
your kid's bringing you out
you know who's the who's the person he's
looking at what are the courses they're
playing that he likes and how does that
become part of
part of the uh you know the landscape of
fandom
and that to me that's it's there's a lot
that goes into
answering that question but it's
it's it's doable it's doable and golf's
kind of in this perilous phase right now
where it's like it could go one way or
the other
i mean there's such a draw on attention
spans out there i mean
short attention spans there's a million
ways you
a million things you can consume a
million ways you can consume them
how is golf going to distinguish itself
and right now they have the four majors
in the ryder cup and after that it's not
that it and
and tiger woods and after that it's just
not
what's bringing people to the tv and or
to your tablet you know like what what's
doing it uh
and there's a lot of questions that golf
has to answer
um i mean that's a part of the
soul-searching they're gonna have to do
and hopefully guided by
a lot of the precedent that you talk
about in this lovely book
i want to conclude with a couple
questions about your future uh first uh
do you think
i think i came away naturally wondering
well let me take another sport that i'm
not that interested in
um that uh some people play mostly in
the northern part of the country
in canada et cetera although some play
out here and then
you know kind of give the same this
regalis treatment to it and that's
hockey which you obviously cover
it's played with a stick uh kind of
looks a little bit like it and if you're
what happy gilmore adam sandler's
character you
can hit like that uh is that a
possibility on the horizon for you a
hockey's holy war um
you know i thought this was a very
specific thing that was going on in the
game of golf right now so
it's not like hey i banged out my golf
book now the next is the hockey book
it's just this was a very specific um
thing i wanted to get into and and and
like we were talking about before it's
like what what you're most curious about
is what you're gonna you know be the
best at so
golf to me was always it's always you
know it's the forefront of my mind
constantly so
you know this took a long time to do and
the only reason i was able to get
through it was because i care so much
about the game and i i care about what i
was writing about so
and that's not to say i don't care about
hockey i do but i don't it's not quite
the i don't
see the same wow who knows maybe there's
a great story out there in hockey that i
just haven't seen yet
[Music]
but i would love for you to explore that
as i said i mean i think if you can
bring interest to somebody who
began the reading of the book the
listening to of the book um
you know so close to it and feeling that
there is this other dimension and there
is something for
for anyone who is interested and curious
about the game because it has a
technical
i always forget if i'm left brain or
right brain but it has both sides of the
brain
you know which probably means i'm only
one side or half of the side of the
brain anyway
um so conclusion um i want to ask you
guys a couple of uh
of dif i'll ask you a couple of
questions uh um
mainly about the kind of influence of
physics you talked and we talked on
twitter a couple times about
you know kind of your math phobia your
but you have these pretty high
high high brow topics and discussions of
things like string theory m
theory etc uh what what about
physics of course there's a famous book
called the physics of golf you probably
have it on your shelf somewhere in the
back i can't see it if you don't i'll
get you a copy of it it's a wonderful
book
and it's it's you know full of equations
so it won't get
more than one one thousand twenty-fourth
of the number of books
of of uh readers as you have but
nevertheless
um you know it kind of layers into it a
little bit more and there's a book the
physics of baseball which is nicely
paired with moneyball or something like
that as well
but the the question of you know kind of
the influence of physics to you it seems
like it has
it has a pretty a pretty lofty at least
place in your reverence
for subjects i don't know of too many
physicists who actually played golf i
mean physicists have been interested in
in baseball talked about baseball of
course they're interested in all sorts
of casino games like poker et cetera
they're interested in you know playing
the bongos or something i just wonder
what is it about physics specifically or
why is it what is it about golf maybe
that doesn't appeal to physicists or
or maybe conversely what appeals uh to
golfers so much about physics and you
and
in particular well
to me physics is uh
it's a study of the physical world right
so
how is golf not affected by that and not
just like
the geometry right it's not like that
because that's like almost a separate
thing it's it's to me
like what what you guys what modern
physicists are doing
is is as interesting as anything i can
think of
and i don't understand almost all of it
right but the
but the little pieces that i do
understand how do you how do you not
how are you not interested in the makeup
of the physical world
right and and the more i've learned
about it
um the more interesting it gets to me
so if you if i'm if i'm writing a book
about golf
how does the makeup of the universe not
come into play right it has to
because it comes into play on everything
right so
you know there was a couple uh
revelations for me
um you know where i was i was an english
guy i was a literature english guy and i
remember i bought
um i bought the elegant universe in a
bookstore
and that was and i remember i remember i
remember to clear his day it was
probably
i don't know 10 years 10 years ago or so
i was sitting on my couch that was the
first time i understood relativity
my whole life and so which is sad
probably for my education
but uh you know i was yeah
and to me that was it and then i fell
off this cliff
of reading of reading everything i get
my hands on because
i didn't understand quantum mechanics i
didn't understand uncertainty
all of that stuff and then you know
stephen hawking in black holes which is
your specialty in that you know i didn't
understand any of that but i don't
unders
i don't get how people are not
interested in that
um and to me so
i think probably physicists don't care
that much about
sports because it seems trivial compared
to what they're doing
where i don't understand why more
golfers aren't drawn to that
too because maybe they're a little more
sportsman and and
you know jock if you will and so but
there there's definitely in
in the middle of that venn diagram there
there are a lot of people
you know i found something interesting
too where uh
you think in this in this time where
everyone's becoming more analytical that
more people would be drawn to
this the the uh um
golfing machine type of archetype but
way more people have read golf in the
kingdom i get
which is this very spiritual kind of
semi-fantastical book
i get people saying that all the time
like oh man i read golf in the kingdom
and
and it really resonated with me and and
more so than anything else
i didn't know anyone else had read it or
or i didn't know
it before i read your book and now i
picked it up and read it and it's like
my favorite thing so
people attach themselves to that
spirituality of it too
but to me that that links right into
modern science too we're like oh maybe
they're
maybe you're trying to figure it out
maybe there's more to
this picture than meets the eye maybe
there's more to space
time than than you know the four
dimensions we we know
um so i think they're i think it's
linked i think it's
it's it's for me at least it's it's
incredibly linked and i can't
i really can't detach the two and i'm
happy
i'm happy you didn't rip on me for
getting straight fury wrong and so which
i'm sure i did in some regard but
yeah we'll talk about that later off
camera
but i want to conclude with a very
serious question and that is um
have you landed bret uh brad pitt to
play you in the movie version of golf's
holy war i just assumed that was what
was going to happen but i'll have my
agent working on this
yeah oh brett cergals has been a joy to
talk to you a little bit different
uh attack for me on the into the
impossible podcast but maybe not so much
because we got into science and even
string theory
but we discussed the soul and the other
aspects that i think resonates so
so beautifully in this wonderful book
golf's holy war i've been speaking with
brett sir dallas
who's a writer for the new york post he
covers uh he covers hockey and
baseball as well as golf obviously and
he's a member of the
metropolitan golf riders association in
lives on long island
and where i came from my ancestral
homeland so it's good to talk to a
fellow islander too bad the islanders
themselves are not going to make it to
the stanley cup this year but
hope springs eternal you're talking to
somebody from san diego where we have
the easiest
possible jobs for weather reporters
uh but the hardest jobs for
sportscasters so
ever if you ever want to challenge come
out here and report although the padres
made the playoffs so i'm pretty excited
yeah well you got something and that's
beautiful baseball weather too
everybody yes golfing baseball i'd love
to play around with you someday
brett maybe out here and torrey pines
beautifully located
right adjacent to campus at university
of california san diego or there on long
island
uh my ancestral home in your current
home brett sirgales thank you so much
for joining us on the into the
impossible podcast
thanks so much for having me brian
appreciate it
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from the magic
[Music]
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible with professor brian keating
please subscribe comment share and
review
watch on youtube listen on itunes
spotify google player stitcher
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information and to sign up for
professor keating's mailing list
go to dr briankeeting.com
that's dr bryankeeting.com
follow professor keating on medium and
twitter at
dr brian heating dr brian keating
for more information on the clark center
go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
at the university of california san
diego in the division of physical
sciences
eric very director ryan keating
co-director
produced by ryan keating and stuart
valco